en esta casa los tranquilos suburbios de
rotterdam el tiempo parece haberse
detenido en 2014 si le han perdió a su
hijo y a su nuera en el ataque al vuelo
17 durante los últimos siete años ha
mantenido su habitación intacta no puede
deshacerme de nada simplemente no puede
sigue siendo su habitación es todo lo
que nos queda embrujada
todo sigue igual desde sus muertes
excepto el contenido de este cajón
estas son cenizas del lugar de la
actividad más
el resto de la casa se convirtió en un
memorial
debido a la penumbra que rodea la
catástrofe si leen y su marido no han
podido hacer el duelo
cuando nos reunimos en familia por el
motivo que sea siempre nos ponemos un
plato de comida y
bronx una bebida una copa de vino para
basic y un whisky para abrirlos
prendemos velas y hablamos mucho de ello
todo el tiempo
no hicimos nada pero estamos condenados
de por vida estos son nuestros discursos
un desconcierto el que podrán hablar en
los tribunales si leen y robb se han
estado preparando durante meses siento
que lo hago por grises y beiges y soy su
voz
el 17 de julio de 2014 un avión de
malaysia airlines despegó de amsterdam
hacia kuala lumpur pero sobre el este de
ucrania región sacudida por un conflicto
separatista éste fue derribado en el
aire por un misil ruso el ataque dejó un
balance de 298 muertos de los cuales dos
tercios eran neerlandeses como resultado
del juicio se está llevando a cabo en
los países bajos
volvemos a ver a rocchia si leen en este
tribunal de alta seguridad están a punto
de dar el testimonio más desgarrador de
sus vidas vinieron con las cenizas de su
hijo
[Música]
cómo voy a formar el 6 de enero
y
así será
fue un momento desgarrador para los
afligidos padres pero esencial para si
leen
pudimos retratar bien abrirse a daisy
los jueces saben que hubo 298 víctimas
pero al hablar les dimos un rostro a las
víctimas y
también explicamos lo que significa para
nosotros como familiares
este tipo de testimonio de los
familiares sólo es posible en los países
bajos desde 2005 un total de 91
familiares de las víctimas subirán al
estrado esto es insólito en el país este
abogado tuvo que preparar a sus clientes
para el ejercicio no hay un testimonio
bueno o malo es su historia personal
pueden decir lo que quieran lo único que
no es sensato es hablarles a los
sospechosos directamente decirles
hicieron esto y lo otro cometieron un
asesinato no ellos siguen siendo
sospechosos es el tribunal el que debe
condenarlos no los familiares de las
víctimas
los sospechosos son un ucraniano y tres
rusos se les condena de haber
transportado el misil a la zona de
lanzamiento están siendo juzgados en
ausencia pero la mayoría de los
testimonios de los familiares la
responsabilidad también recae en rusia
antes de hablar frente al tribunal [__]
quiere esperar a que se presenten todas
las pruebas de
la federación de rusia también jugó un
papel en el accidente del m 17 el
sistema de misiles vino de rusia los
separatistas cuentan con el apoyo de
rusia y ellos también el control de
facto del este de ucrania así que tienen
una gran responsabilidad y lo niegan
todo
este juicio es muy importante con los
cuatro sospechosos pero también porque
el tribunal se pronunciará sobre los
misiles utilizados y la zona de
lanzamiento y eso dice mucho sobre la
participación rusa
rusia rechazó la creación de un tribunal
penal internacional pero su
responsabilidad está siendo examinada
por el tribunal europeo de derechos
humanos
el caso presentado ante el tribunal
neerlandés y el caso presentado ante el
tribunal europeo de derechos humanos son
paralelos con dos juicios distintos pero
tienen el mismo objetivo la destrucción
del vuelo m17 en los países bajos se
juzga a los autores se les juzga como
personas en el tribunal europeo de
derechos humanos se juzga en acción se
espera que la sentencia se dicte antes
de finales del próximo año en el juicio
de los países bajos
los familiares saben que esto es solo un
paso en el largo camino judicial